[Música]
el número de refugiados y desplazados
internos en todo el mundo alcanzó a
finales del año 2021 una cifra récord de
89.3 millones de personas pero en este
año 2022 ya ha superado los 100 millones
a causa de los conflictos como el de
clanes por ejemplo esto según la agencia
de naciones unidas para los refugiados
conflictos persecuciones violencia
violaciones de derechos humanos
provocaron que en 2021 esta cifra de
refugiados y desplazados internos
aumentará por décimo año consecutivo por
lo que este colectivo se ha duplicado
con respecto a hace una década cuando no
alcanzaba apenas los 43 millones este
informe se publica cada año en vísperas
del día mundial de los refugiados que se
conmemora todos los 20 de junio y
contabiliza tantos refugiados que son
las personas que huyen de sus países de
origen otros como los desplazados
internos en naciones sacudidas por todos
los conflictos la violencia y también
las graves crisis para ello quiero
saludar entonces a nuestra segunda mitad
del día ella ese civil aprox inscribo
será regional para acnur en las américas
civil a gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros esta mañana del jueves en
directo américa de france 24 según este
informe que presentaron el que
presentará con la mayor cantidad de
refugiados y desplazados internos se da
en países como siria venezuela y
afganistán háblenos entonces por favor
similar a la situación de estos
territorios
como bien dijiste en la introducción
estamos viendo números sin precedentes
de personas
forzadas a huir de sus hogares de sus
países
y es un número realmente preocupante
hubiéramos querido nunca llegar a esta
cifra de 100 millones de personas
desplazadas forzosamente
este
y en nuestra región en américa latina
están el 20 por ciento de este número de
personas
obligados a huir y esto es una crisis
realmente sin precedentes en la región y
claramente en
en el mundo hablemos ahora por supuesto
civil de la situación de los casi 5
millones de ucranianos que han huido a
otros países desde que comenzó la
invasión dulce el pasado 24 de febrero
sí
digamos nuestro informe que sacamos hoy
de los
89,3 millones de personas desplazadas no
incluye
a los ciclones porque estos soy persona
cierre del 2021
la crisis en ucrania la guerra en
ucrania
lastimosamente ha aumentado el número de
personas huyendo
es una situación de rápido crecimiento
y en los países vecinos
han sido supremamente solidarios en
recibir a de estas personas refugiadas y
la comunidad internacional ha sido
también muy generosa en apoyar y
digamos la recepción de estas personas y
lo que has digamos el llamado que
hacemos desde acnur es que haya esa
misma respuesta es el mismo nivel de
solidaridad
de comprensión con todos los otros
refugiados en el mundo de diferentes
situaciones
claro que lamentablemente es que a eso
también iván no se ve por ejemplo con
refugiados africanos refugiados de
varios países de áfrica pero hablando
también de los países receptores que los
invitados que también abrir estas
puertas cuáles son los países que en la
actualidad más reciben migrantes
mira estamos hablando de refugiados los
países receptores
invariablemente los que más reciben
refugiados son los países cercanos a los
países que están expulsando personas
refugiadas entonces lo que significa que
la gran mayoría son son países que
colindan que son vecinos a los países en
conflicto a los países de los que huyen
las personas entonces
es una
digamos es una
una actitud es una apertura a personas
refugiadas en países muchas veces en
desarrollo que necesitan mucho apoyo de
la comunidad internacional para seguir
acogiendo a las personas que necesitan
esta ayuda en esta protección
internacional claro eso también lo decía
países en desarrollo nos venimos a
nuestra región para dar un ejemplo por
colombiano que reciba 1.8
millones de migrantes venezolanos o
incluso más que es un país también con
muchas problemáticas pues que está
acogiendo y ayudando a estos migrantes
venezolanos pero también entre todo este
grupo en este grupo de migrantes están
los menores de edad que lamentablemente
son los más vulnerables los grandes
afectados los niños que se cuentan entre
las principales víctimas de este éxodo
ya representan como lícitamente informe
un 30 por ciento de la población
refugiada y un 42 por ciento de la que
sufre un desplazamiento interno cómo
hacer para que esto no ocurra no creo
que no sufran digamos porque pues no
podemos hacer nada para que estas
desgracias y estas tragedias no ocurran
en los países pero cómo hacer para
mitigar el sufrimiento de estos menores
de edad
bueno como como bien lo dices los niños
son entre la población refugiada más
vulnerable las atenciones tienen que ser
diferenciadas para diferentes
necesidades de
las personas refugiadas y obligadas a ir
a tantos niños y mujeres
personas con discapacidades
personas digamos que tienen necesidades
específicas
más allá de la necesidad muy básica de
atención humanitaria hay poblaciones que
necesitan
atención específica para su condición
pero no quería volver si me permites el
tema de los países de acogida
para destacar que en nuestra región en
américa latina
están el tercer y cuarto país en el
mundo que más solicitudes de asilo
recibieron en el 2021 que son mexico que
está en el tercer puesto después de eeuu
y alemania y costa rica que que también
ha recibido un número sin precedentes de
solicitudes